any time i had to kiss jennifer was
pretty uncomfortable
who would have thought cozying up with
an incredibly attractive actor would be
so
awkward filming intimate scenes for
movies and
tv shows are very often actors least
favorite part of production whether it's
the crew watching as they bear it all
or the pressure to live up to fans
steamy expectations
let's take a look at the scenes that
actors were uncomfortable filming
don't be a coward kristen stewart and
robert pattinson were the faces of
twilight
and the star couple both on and off
screen
but the anticipated love scene between
bella and edward had even more pressure
thanks to twilight author stephanie
meyer's
lofty description and stewart was
understandably frustrated
it had to be transcendent and
otherworldly
inhuman and we were like how do we live
up to that
and i die you die turn bright right
die harry potter stars emma watson and
daniel radcliffe had quite the awkward
scene in deathly hallows part one
as if a passionate kiss between long
time friends wasn't enough
the intimate moment also had some
additional requirements
they were like oh and p.s we hope you
don't mind but we'd like you both to be
topless and covered in silver paint
kissing rupert uh
also awkward the awkwardness continued
when
watson and actor rupert grint came
together for ron and hermione's much
anticipated kiss in harry potter and the
deathly hallows part two
and the two childhood friends certainly
felt weird about it
it's obviously hard to put our personal
history to one side considering that we
did grow up together while fans might
look back on that scene with fondness
rupert grint never watches it one take
was enough
i bun for you
for bridgerton leads phoebe dynavore and
reggae jean-page
there were some unique challenges when
it came to their numerous
love scenes especially for dinavore's
solo scene
that was the hardest scene to shoot you
feel very vulnerable in those scenes
the actors also had to be wary of the
very expensive and
delicate furniture on set even the bed
could you please go easy on the bed it's
very very hard young stranger things
stars millie bobby brown and finn
wolfhard
had some pretty uncomfortable first
kisses
it was my first kiss not only were there
a bunch of crew and extras watching
their parents were there too
my dad watched the whole thing my whole
family was there and it was the most
awkward thing in the world and finn
found his own kissing technique
particularly cringe-worthy i kissed her
so
it looks like i was eating her like i
was like ah like that
fellow stranger things actor sadie sink
also had a similarly awkward first kiss
experience with co-star caleb mclaughlin
not only was the kiss not originally
written in the script
the two had to do it in front of a bunch
of people both
on and off camera like 200 extras and
then like all of their parents and then
the whole crew
and my mom euphoria's first episode
introduces the on-screen couple algae
smith and sydney sweeney with a pretty
graphic love scene
after replacing another actor who had
trouble with the material
algae also admitted to having some
trouble with it as well
it was an uncomfortable scene for me but
i had to learn how to separate myself
and just be the actor
hello i love you more
sex education lead actor asa butterfield
had to perform a particularly
uncomfortable set of intimate scenes all
by himself
he admittedly found it very strange to
reenact such a private thing in front of
the whole crew
the first couple of times are awkward
and it's like i can't believe that i'm
doing this
i like looking at it and going oh god
i'm sorry let's go again
game of thrones stars emilia clarke and
kit harrington
did not particularly enjoy their love
scene in the season seven finale while
the production only needed three shots
to do the scene
that did little to lessen the discomfort
if you've known someone for six years
there's something unnatural and strange
about doing a love scene
it's gonna i mean i think kind of i
might be the reaction
nicole kidman took to heart the
harrowing experiences her character was
having on the series big little lies
she and co-star alexander skarsgard had
a number of rough love scenes that at
the time left her vulnerable and
deeply humiliated i remember lying on
the floor in the bathroom and i just
wouldn't get up in between takes
when i first read that scene in the
script i just
cried mayor of east town actors and gary
rice and kia mckiernan were
understandably nervous for their first
intimate scene together but veteran
actor kate winslet came to the rescue
she promised to be present for their
scene and ended up hiding in the trunk
of the car they were filming in so the
camera wouldn't see her
nobody needs me i need you
yet another pair of actors that had a
tough time kissing their co-star were
hunger games leads
josh hutcherson and liam hemsworth
jennifer lawrence would purposely eat
garlic or tuna before smooching her good
friend hemsworth while hutcherson would
often complain about slobber and dribble
when it came to locking lips with her
alison hannigan and jason seagal starred
as the lovey-dovey couple marshall and
lily on how i met your mother but for a
while hannigan hated kissing her co-star
because he was a big time smoker it's
like kissing an ashtray and he's trying
to be polite by having gum or mints but
it doesn't
lil you help damn it oscar winner
jennifer lawrence makes another
appearance but this time she's the one
who was uncomfortable
on the 2016 film passengers she had
trouble getting intimate with co-star
chris pratt
who at the time was married to actress
anna faris
lawrence decided to get drunk before
their romantic scene but that only made
her feel guiltier
so i called my mom i was like well you
just told me it's okay
um it was just very vulnerable another
actor that hated locking lips with their
co-star was miles teller
on the film the spectacular now actor
shailene woodley would take
chinese herbal supplements before
kissing teller in order to get revenge
teller would drink gatorade to make sure
their scenes were just as unbearable for
her as they were
for him actors kristen wiig and jon hamm
found themselves in quite an
uncomfortable position on bridesmaids
the two friends view each other as
siblings which made their love scene in
the film
all the more awkward ham's weird attire
didn't help either
it's not a lot of fun rolling around in
front of 30 or 40 crew members in a
flesh-colored thong
it was just your just butt is out there
there's the camera crew and that's your
butt if you've seen david fincher's 2014
thriller gone girl
then it's not a stretch to buy that neil
patrick harris had
an unpleasant experience when it came
time to do a gory love scene with
actress rosamond pike harris said
fincher required them to rehearse
a lot we had to just practice that which
is awkward and weird for hours
when you go on your honeymoon soon and
you're not invited
in one of the more nauseating onset
experiences reese witherspoon had to
make
out with a very sick robert pattinson
during production of the film water for
elephants
pattinson was reportedly battling a
terrible cold
making the handsome actor a nightmare to
kiss witherspoon claimed he was
sniffling and dripping snot the entire
time
gross the iconic upside-down kissing
scene from the 2002 spider-man movie was
actually a nightmare for lead actor
toby mcguire he was reluctant to do it
at all since he could already
tell how unpleasant it was going to be
besides dealing with having to hang
upside down he also had to put up with
rain water going up his nose
it was it was torture it makes you
realize how important oxygen is
starring in the 2009 movie avatar zoe
saldana and sam worthington had an
awkward love scene that didn't make the
final cut
saldana claimed it was the unique
approach to the film
that made it so challenging there were
so many technical things that sometimes
you have to keep in mind
that paying attention to all those might
disrupt the fluidity of how a scene
is supposed to take place i've already
chosen
but this woman must also choose me did
you know that film and tv productions
have started making
intimacy coordinators a staple on set
their job is to guide actors through
intimate scenes just like the ones we've
listed bridgerton's phoebe denivore and
reggae jean page
raved about their experience with their
intimacy coordinator
who helped them through those steamy
scenes that had the whole world
talking